ボリ、ボリ....
はじめ) ある日のことでした。
所沢くんが
こんなことを言い出したのです。
ボリ、ボリ....
所沢) はじめん...
はじめん...
はじめ) え!?
所沢) ぼく...
恋人が欲しい...
はじめ) え!!
所沢) ぼく...
さみしい...
のこままだと...
独身で死んじまう!!
はじめ 心) そっかー、そうだよなー。
はじめ) 恋人かー。w
はじめ 心) この子いつも一人だし
友達のダークネス井上も東京に行っちゃったしな。
ここは一肌脱いでやりますか!!
はじめ) よし!!
分かった!
俺が何とかしてやるよ!
所沢) え!
本当!?
はじめ) だから...
待っててくれ。
バタバタバタバタバタバタバタバタ
はぁ、はぁ、はぁ...
ペタッ
パン!
はじめ) うぇーぁぅー.
ハッ、ハッ、ハッ、ハッ、
ガン!
うわ、ぁ、あ。
ポイ!
はじめ) はぁっ笑
所沢。
連れて来だぞ。
所沢) んぅ??
キョロ?
はじめん!!!
はじめ) よし! 開けていきます!
バン!
バシ! バシ! バシ、バシ、バシ、バシバシバシバシ......
はじめ) どうやって開けようか?
あ! もう出てきちゃってる!
待って、頑張ってここから開けよう!
ペリ、ぺリッ、
いけそう!
待ってろー、所沢!
ベリ、ベリ、ベリ、
はじめ) うぉーわぁ。
おらぁー。
あっ!
待って、まだ
まだ早い、まだ早い。
ベリベリベリッ!
あっ!  あっ!! あっ!!! あっ!!
ちょっと待って笑
うわぁ。
あ!!
あぁ!
あぁーは!!
待てこれ難しいな。
ちょっとww
出てき方が。
ピンククマ) やめて、はじめん!! 恥ずかしい////
はじめ) ちょっと待って、
そう言うのじゃないんで!
そう言うのじゃないんで! (2回目)
ピンククマ) ////////////♡
スポッ!
はじめ) おっ!!
はじめ) はっ
うぅ..
おらぁーあー。
はぁー、はぁー、はぁー、
はいっ!!!
すいません。
あの、袋から出たばっかりでちょっと不細工です。
ま、徐々に可愛くなっていくとは思うんですけど、
ちょっと、袋からお出たばっかりで不細工なんで
ちょっと、許してほしいところではあります。
寄り添って♡
はい
あ、かわいい/// (棒)
かわいい♡
うわぁーぁ。
はい。とう言うわけで、ダークネス井上
あの、紫色い友達がずっといたと思うんですけども
あの子多分しばらく東京から帰って来ないっす。
ちょっと、所沢がさみしいなっと
さみしいなと言うことで
今回、所沢の、
あのー、
恋人のー、
?????
やばい、名前どうしよう。
えーと....
えー、山岸めぐみちゃんです。
宜しくお願い致します。
はい。
なぜかフルネームです。
いや、良かったー。
これで多分この子ももう
ほらっ!
なんか久しぶりにこんな背筋がピンとした
所沢を見た気がするんですけど
いや、なかなか
お似合いだと思いますよ。(棒)
かわいいな!
ぁっ!
君たちお似合いだね。
バッチリお似合いだと思います。
いやー、良かったなー所沢、お前。
お似合いだぜ!
おらーっ!!!!!
あぁぁー!
ぎゅー!
なんで??
ぎゅぅー!!!
ぎゅっ!
あ!    あぁ、あぁ、いい、いい、いい!
いい、お似合い お似合い♡
お似合い、お似合い、お似合い。
はい、という訳でちょっと寂しそうだったんで
所沢の恋人を準備してあげました。
はぁ♡
え?
ほんとに可愛いな♡
うわぁー////
2人は、永遠の愛を、誓いますか?
はい。(2人)
誓いのキスを。
ヴァコーン!
チュッ💋
おめでとうございます。
パチパチパチパチ.....
はいという訳で、これからですね
所沢とめぐみちゃんのお二人を
どうぞ、宜しくお願い致します。(はじめの枕)
ペコ。
ばいばい!!!
あぁ、はっ...